(missile roaring)
- [Reporter] Ukrainian
forces have repeatedly asked
the US for these.
They're the Army Tactical Missile System,
ATACMS for short.
These missiles can come equipped
with a 500-pound blast
fragmentation warhead
and have a maximum range
of about 190 miles,
which could allow Ukrainian forces
to reach further into
Russian-held territories
inside Ukraine, including Crimea.
In September, US officials said
they would send a small
number of ATACMS missiles
to Ukraine in coming weeks
after debating the risk of
escalating tensions with Russia
and worrying about its
small domestic stockpile.
- We've been supplying Ukraine
with items from our junk drawer,
as opposed to the high-end
missile capabilities.
(missile roaring)
- [Reporter] Here's how
these missiles could speed up
Ukraine's counteroffensive against Russia,
and why the US was initially
hesitant to send them.
- ATACMS is the Army Field Artillery's
premier surface-to-surface strike system.
It allows them to be mobile, to disperse,
to hide in terrain and clutter,
and to be able to impose
certain kinds of uncertainty
upon the enemy about where
they'll be coming from.
- [Reporter] The ATACMS
is designed to be launched
from a ground vehicle, like the US HIMARS,
which is already in Ukraine.
Once the missile is fired,
(missile roaring)
the ground vehicle can shoot and scoot
to avoid retaliatory attacks.
This could be a huge advantage
for Ukrainian forces,
which have been using a similar missile,
the UK's Storm Shadow,
that's fired from an airborne jet.
- It just offers one
more level of flexibility
for the counteroffensive.
The other systems that
require launching by air
limit where and when the
Ukrainians can use them.
They need that air platform.
This essentially empowers ground forces
to take these launchers
anywhere they need them.
(radio chattering)
- One of the interesting
features of the HIMARS launcher
is that it doesn't reveal exactly
what missile it's carrying.
That's advantageous,
because assuming an
enemy is surveilling you,
won't necessarily know what's inside
and won't know whether it
is a higher-value ATACMS,
as opposed to the shorter-range stuff.
- [Reporter] This gives Ukrainians
the added advantage of firing missiles
from multiple types of domains,
including air and ground.
But the HIMARS' mobility
means that Ukrainians
could get closer to Russian territory,
further increasing the missiles' reach.
ATACMS missiles can reach up to 190 miles,
considerably farther than
the Storm Shadow's top range
of 155 miles.
- There's just all kinds
of operational advantages
to that greater range.
That reach allows, for instance,
Ukrainian forces to be able
to fire from safer territory,
to not have to walk right
up to the Russian lines
to be able to hit something deeper back.
- [Reporter] This additional
range could force Moscow
to move storage facilities
and command centers
more than 200 miles from the front,
and that could complicate
efforts to supply troops
with food and ammunition,
aiding Ukrainians in
their counteroffensive.
Plus...
- This weapon could be useful
for getting a Ukrainian targeting
inside some of these
Russian hell territories,
specifically Crimea.
- [Reporter] ATACMS can also move
significantly faster than other missiles,
reaching a top speed of Mach 3,
or around 2,300 miles per hour.
In contrast, cruise missiles
like the Storm Shadow
or Russia's KH-101, for example,
have top speeds of only around
600 to 700 miles per hour.
- The speed of the ATACMS
is simply a function of the fact
that it's a ballistic missile
with a big rocket engine,
single stage, on the back.
This speed is useful for
time-critical targets,
things that may move,
that need to be hit very promptly.
- [Reporter] The ATACMS guidance system
combines inertial navigation with GPS.
This creates highly accurate targeting,
preventing electronic
jamming and interference
and minimizing collateral
damage on impact.
ATACMS are also designed with features
adept at hitting multiple
types of targets.
These missiles are highly
maneuverable in the air,
allowing them to hit targets
from a variety of angles.
- Simple ballistic missile
is gonna travel on a ballistic trajectory.
It's gonna just follow gravity's rainbow,
something that's very
predictable and curved.
The benefit of maneuverability
is that you can interrupt that rainbow.
You can come down in a different way.
You can maneuver to be more on target.
You can go after, perhaps, a moving target
and correct for for errors.
And yes, you can come down
vertically, if you'd like.
That vertical impact may be useful
to come right over top of target
and just make it that much
harder for it to see it coming,
or to hit the vulnerable
spot on an armored vehicle.
- [Reporter] ATACMS missiles can contain
one of two types of warheads,
unitary or submunition.
- A unitary warhead is
just what it sounds like.
It is one big explosive.
It's in one piece.
Submunitions, or bomblets,
are likewise what they sound like,
lots of little things that spread out.
There's advantages to both,
depending on what you're targeting.
- [Reporter] Inside an
ATACMS submunition warhead
are hundreds of steel-cased balls
filled with incendiary pellets.
- Which could be likened
crudely to a shotgun blast
(gunshot booming)
where it has a large
spray of explosive impact
on the target.
And then there's a unitary warhead,
which would be crudely likened
to a single bullet out of a pistol.
(gunshot booming)
- [Reporter] Unitary warheads are better
at targeting specific single targets,
while submunition warheads
are highly effective
against moving personnel and equipment.
- The unitary and the submunitions
are admittedly tailored
for different things,
but both of them can go after
lots of different targets.
- What we don't know is what
variant they would provide
or what combination of variants
they would provide to the Ukrainians.
- [Reporter] Despite Ukraine's requests,
the US was hesitant to
send ATACMS until now.
- There was concerns about escalating
the conflict with the Russians.
There's concerns that the Ukrainians
could use these ATACMS,
which have this long range,
and target inside Russian territory.
But we're also at a point
in the counteroffensive,
which, it's gone a lot
slower than anybody expected.
And so, the US may be digging
deeper into its pockets
and green-lighting other weapons systems
that it didn't wanna provide before,
given the time constraints.
- [Reporter] The Biden administration
faced increased pressure
from Ukraine and Congress
to send ATACMS missiles.
Last June, Congress signed
a bipartisan resolution
in favor of sending ATACMS to Ukraine,
and the administration has reversed course
on weapons before,
like with the Abrams tank.
But officials have also expressed concern
about the US's domestic ATACMS stockpile.
- US is really trying to balance
its own national security needs
with those of Ukraine and Europe at large.
- And the United States just doesn't have
a whole lot of these lying around.
They've been out of production
to some extent for some time.
- [Reporter] This recent reversal
comes shortly after a
US Army official said
that the replacement missile
for the ATACMS, the PrSM,
will be out of production
and entering US stockpiles
in the near future.
The PrSM, or Precision Strike Missile,
can reach over 300 miles,
which is significantly
farther than the ATACMS.
- That may also mitigate
some of the impact
on the US inventory to provide the ATACMS.
That's opening the door for
potentially providing them now.